[Music]
what's a better soldier you're my dad
careful
come on let's go did you actually see my
dad's wife yes
we looked after each other like brothers
yeah kind of like brothers
james the cleaning house
you're leaving the army with an
honorable discharge but you're losing
your pension and health care
we gave them our minds our bodies and
our spirit
they'd shoot us up and spit us out
i just want to check in with y'all on
your past due payment message deleted
what you did in uniform sledgehammer
[ __ ]
our thing scalpel work
we operate a deep black oga offshoot
with direct presidential authority
bank some decent cash put a down payment
on the house
that's not dangerous now i know you're
lying maybe i need to take care of my
family so what do you say you're down
for the cause yeah
salim mohammed mosu study pathogenic
influenza viruses in humans
we all know what one motivated radical
can do
so let's cowboy up get it done and get
home to our families you don't
understand what you're doing i'm trying
to save lives
this is only about money
what do we do mike
i've got an extraction team brown bmw x1
comply i'll do that when you confirm who
you're working for you work for me
you gotta trust me i am trying to help
you oh we're working for the president
corporations
they train us to run their errands
kill their enemies and kill each other
easy to kill but it's much harder to
survive
need to get back home
home's in memory
he's going to come after you with
everything he's got
[Music]
i'm going home
[Music]
[Music]
you